8 mars journée internationale des femmes
une journée que le chef de l'état a
voulu marquer au conseil des ministres
en déclarant qu'il restait encore je le
cite beaucoup à faire pour que la dans
la vie quotidienne
las les hommes et les femmes vivent
libres et égaux en droits à paris cette
journée a été marquée par les états
généraux des femmes à la sorbonne des
états généraux qui était organisée par
l'alliance des femmes pour la
démocratisation
patrice jacquin 8 mars 1857 à new york
des couturières descendre dans la rue
pour réclamer l'égalité des salaires
avec les hommes
depuis les femmes ont fait du 8 mars
leur journée et aujourd'hui l'alliance
des femmes pour la démocratisation avait
convoqué ces états généraux
au programme deux autres anniversaires
le bicentenaire bien sûr avec un hommage
à celle qui ont fait 1789 et aussi le
vingtième anniversaire du début des
luttes du mlf
on constate de grands progrès dans les
droits civiques économiques ou sociaux
des femmes mais aussi que l'égalité dans
les fêtes n'existe pas il y à toujours
plus de filles au chômage que de garçons
sans parler du décalage dans les
salaires et des difficultés à trouver sa
place dans la vie politique
mais au delà ce qui manque le plus c'est
peut-être un grand projet aujourd'hui il
faut à nouveau réaliser de grands
desseins
quant aux pies et je pense que lui la
volonté la détermination la maturité que
nous avons acquise doivent s'investir
dans un projet de conquête politique
n'est pas n'importe quel pouvoir pas à
n'importe quel prix et pas sur le non de
conservateur et comme l'a très bien dit
colette audry ce matin comme les projets
comme ceux qui amènent benazir buttho
dans un pays musulman à la tête de
l'état ça c'est extraordinaire
le féminisme n'est donc pas mort reste
désormais à lui trouver un souffle
nouveau